the Joe Rogan experience when you're
watching this from the outside and
you're seeing all this technology
develop are you concerned at all when
you see how addicted people are to their
phones because this like your games are
very addictive in the best ways right
the quake is super addictive it's really
fun it's great to play and that's why
it's addictive because you just want to
get that charge that rush to get back in
there but the odd thing to me about cell
phone addiction is there's not much
thrill
it's a weird addiction we're just
constantly checking and nothing's coming
back like people are just constantly
checking their email and their their
Twitter messages their DMS and YouTube
videos but there's not a lot coming back
at you I'm I'm concerned I see this
thing where you'll go to a place and
you'll see 80% of the people just
looking at their phones and not
interacting with people do you ever like
look at that and go where's this going
so I do think about this in a way that
because this is one of these things
where I recognize it in some other
people where I think I probably do
interact with things a little bit
differently and I am sometimes conscious
of the fact that most people don't think
about things the way I do and it's clear
that yes a lot of people just I they get
rage out of Twitter and I don't I can
see it's some people it's probably bad
for them doing some of these social
media things but I mean I I get
inspiration out of Twitter I mean my
feet I'm going through I'm seeing
brilliant scientists new research
developments wonderful art from people
hard workers developing products and I
just look at this as like this is this
amazing set of human beings that are
building the future and I've got this
window into their mind it winds up being
a very positive thing for me but I do
see the people that just wind up having
AI that it is a negative aspect for them
and I don't know what to do about that
because I mean talking about people
issues are obviously not my strong suit
I'm the nuts and bolts or bits and bytes
technology person and social challenges
I mean that's one of the things that
probably over you know over decades I've
just come to be more
at peace with the fact that I probably
do think a bit differently than most
people I don't expect them to you know
to think necessarily like I do and in
many ways that keeps me from being upset
at a lot of people and just say well
people are different they're not going
to process these things the same way
that I do but yeah I can see it as
potentially a problem but I do think
also there's this ability for people to
people always want to say it's ok put
down your phone why aren't you living in
the real world and there's another
aspect of that where for many people the
world that you get in the virtual world
whether it's on your phone or all the
way to VR the whole reason you do that
should be because it's better than the
world that you're choosing to step away
from and again it's harder for many
people that are in an elite
thought-leader position if your life is
awesome in every way then yeah you don't
need that much from the virtual world
whether it's on a cell phone or virtual
reality I mean if you've been you know
courtside backstage pitlane whatever if
you've done all of these things in real
life the VR version of it is not going
to be that compelling and if you saw
people you know fixated and all of that
you'd probably think those people are
not living in reality they should just
be living in reality but for so many
people I you know what they get the
people on the other side of the phone
that they're interacting with that's red
that's where they'd rather be the fact
that people can find their tribe out of
the billions of people in the world even
if they live in some podunk town in the
Midwest
I I think that's a really wonderful
thing and so while yes there is a
negative tail on one side from it i am i
think that this connecting everyone is
largely a good thing on net there are
downsides maybe there should be things
we should be doing to mitigate the
downsides but I think this connection of
humanity is on that a positive thing I
tend to agree with you that it is a
positive thing I think philosophically I
think the way we understand each other
the way we communicate it's very
radically different than our
grandparents and all of it seems to be
moving in a place where we understand
each other better and you're going to
have your side effects like Twitter rage
and and social media bias and you know
these confirmation bias groups where
people just
they sit in these echo chambers and
reiterate the same ideas over and over
again in each other and you're also
going to get people that are
understanding cultures understanding
each other understanding psychology
understanding the way the mind works and
getting access to information at a rate
that's unprecedented in terms of the
knowledge that you can get like just
just being able to google things that's
you know and nobody you know nobody can
actually give them credit for it when
like Mark Zuckerberg and the Facebook
leadership they talk about the mission
is to connect the world and you know of
course it's like oh okay
of course the Facebook CEO is gonna be
mouthing these things but like I really
legitimately do think that the Facebook
leadership is doing this because they
think that's a positive thing and I
agree with them now I'm not a very
social person I'm an introvert I'm a
hermit mode sort of person so much of
the time but I think that this is again
a good thing that connecting more people
giving them the opportunity to find
people that they wouldn't otherwise be
interacting with people they wouldn't
even have known existed in many cases I
think will come out of this you know
looking back decades in the future there
will have been all the tragic things
that happened with social media but on
net it's going to be good
[Applause]